calling a television series based on
pre-existing ip original having this
much body contact with a public pool
wall flirting with someone over a third
party's posterior i know we recently
sent a movie for not showing the
realities of birth but now i'm sitting
this show for depicting a supernatural
birth too realistically so the sin as
always is showing birth at all how much
you want for it as if offering to buy a
baby isn't bad enough heart groups can't
even be bothered to find out the baby's
gender and refers to him or her as it
and would i have sent heart grapes if he
had assumed the gender yes yes i would i
wouldn't dare play the music but trust
me when i say this picture books on for
all the some time i think the show wants
us to shrug off odd behavior due to
hargreaves eccentric lifestyle but
asking all these women to aesthetically
walk in sync like this is just a
ridiculous waste of time show wants us
to believe that vania is the one child
who doesn't have any superpowers yet but
she's a freaking musical prodigy and
plays the violin which if it's not
already should be cited as the superhero
instrument of the musical world get the
[ __ ] out of here with your vania has no
superpowers [ __ ] using precious
water for a dumb plant framing your ugly
sweater family picture we're going now
live to a breaking story i mean of
course we are how else can we let
someone know the heartbreaking truth
about their father's death than by
convenient news position also news
position twice passing a bookstore not
going in and would i have thrown in a
reading scene if vanya had entered the
bookstore yes yes i would also also news
position thrice character mournfully
stares outside a car window after
hearing news of a death in the family
cliche way to dress for the occasion by
the way at least i'm wearing black he
says to allison who for the record is
wearing black pants nothing out of the
ordinary except of course that
everything in this house is out of the
ordinary so maybe the better thing to
say is nothing is ordinary because that
would be more concerning episode teases
us with a super horoscope bonus but
never delivers welcome home miss vanya
i'm not being welcomed home by a monkey
assistant in this scene how long has it
been since five disappeared i understand
that we don't know about five's
disappearance and how long it's been but
vania would know this so why is this
question i'm pretty sure i stepped in
half those peanut butter and marshmallow
sandwiches right but why were the
sandwiches in a place where they'd be
stepped on half the time it's just
an advance on our inheritance
justifying theft of course you don't
know you've
been gone or go with me here because
this may be shocking he doesn't know
because you didn't tell him you can't
just
call dad in the afterlife and be like
dad could you just
stop playing tennis with hitler for a
moment and take a quick call just about
everyone involved gives good
performances here but robert sheehan
steals every scene he's in and deserves
this sin off i've been in many hostage
situations like this and it can escalate
very quickly bragging about being in
many hostage situations as if this is
something to be revered i wouldn't want
you to get hurt or what does everyone
just have to show off their powers each
time they're dealing with a thing diego
or luther should have already dealt with
this guy what if some hostages get shot
because they keep [ __ ] with this guy
waving a gun kids man that's one badass
stapler if i can take a stapler to the
forehead and not pass out a burglar
could do the same though i won't play it
the show thinks lighthearted music will
make children murdering bank robbers
less disturbing the umbrella academy
roll commercials also what were the
other working titles for this academy
parasol sun shade braley or hell go
french with para p academy make it sound
a little more interesting the children
have been gone a long time so this nail
polish should be separated with the
lower half looking all crusty and the
top all oily my favorite part of this
show is how [ __ ] depressing it is to
watch super great introduction to this
world so glad to be here much yay luther
plays i think we're alone now loud
enough for the entire mansion to hear it
in that is absolutely a sin also owning
tiffany on vinyl sure was a good thing
that everyone's room was at the front of
the house for maximum dollhouse effect
scene does not contain pogo dancing i
mean he's tapping his foot but i want to
see the pogo dance i mean at least
there's no way this will be number five
conveniently coming back right after
their father's death and they've been
reminiscing about him damn it so are we
gonna talk about what just happened well
klaus decided to sit on a table with his
bare feet and nobody protested even at a
house funeral it's always raining and
everyone has those [ __ ] black
umbrellas
probably would have been better with
some wind no no actually no who wants to
accidentally breathe in their dead dad's
bits on the wind punching your dead
sibling statue in the dick it's just
like old times random fourth wall
breaking is random i'm taking the car
says the kid who can teleport i know how
to do everything but not this
or this
or this
pompous kid okay you'll just have to
imagine the things i was doing was super
[ __ ] epic because they were let there
be a lesson that there's always more to
learn every single [ __ ] one of these
massive ceiling lights in this old diner
i wouldn't dare play the music but
playing a pleasant they might be giant
song over this violin of a scene does
add some dark humor to proceedings but
now i'll just be thinking about this
dark depressing bloodbath of a scene
every time i listen to tnbg way to
destroy that little birdhouse in my soul
show
eggs please too late for eggs you take
that back you monster it is never too
late or too early for eggs is seven is
seven applying topical medicine to a
bandage that is already on top of a
wound when i jumped forward and got
stuck in the future
do you know what i found
no
nothing except for food and shelter
right because you survived for 45 years
before coming back right as far as i
could tell i was the last person left
alive which makes his earlier mention of
dolores really confusing and maybe the
show will explain it later but i'm here
now damn it and i demand immediate
answers for all things the world ends in
eight days excellent so series is nearly
done
i guess i'm a clumsy mailman you're a
bad
the abs are mailman and it's gluteus to
the maximus here tonight's far far away
royal ball blowout
so here's the rub
somehow we have to have complex
astrophysical engineering conversations
using nothing but a still frame camera
from 1996.
i'm convinced my captors have run out of
food
today i either escape
or perish
good morning dr zero good morning julius
you're crazy you're crazy
boys stop this at once that's a tough
break we got the monkey judge